[Music]
everybody is an individual and everybody
is making decisions to benefit
themselves either as a consumer or as a
business person you know you won't you
want either more consumer goods and more
consumer satisfaction or you want higher
profits for your company so the
discipline of economics is very
individual oriented we talked a little
bit about external benefits and by the
way that is really the rationale for
subsidizing childcare that the benefits
to the children will benefit us all
eventually it's not just sticking with
those children and that's the rationale
for subsidizing education so from an
employer perspective childcare matters
because your employees have a place to
send their child and they're not worried
all during the day about what's
happening to that child and so peace of
mind for employees is very important to
productivity so it's a clear win-win all
of the research on Head Start shows you
the value of taking kids at a young age
and making them ready for kindergarten
and giving them a loving supportive
environment so we're going to save a lot
of money in law enforcement or going to
save money in remedial education it's
just so clear that it's an important
investment
[Music]
when I first came to the business school
this is 1972 Nixon had vetoed a child
care bill in 1971 which would have
provided a national system of child care
and his rationale was that it would
weaken the family so I knew this when I
came here but I had been doing research
on the economics of child care and my
very first faculty seminar at the
Business School was on the economics of
child care in which I argued or tried to
argue that subsidizing childcare would
be a worthwhile economic investment and
my colleagues all white men conservative
white men wouldn't let me give the
seminar they were so outraged at the
notion that I was proposing a subsidy
for childcare that they they just talked
among each other about how at rageous
this was and I was too new to tell them
to be quiet so I could speak and the
person who was running the seminar
didn't tell them to be quiet so I
realized early on that there was just
tremendous opposition to this idea it
would be a good investment for the
government subsidized childcare for
families who can't afford it and for the
rest of the population it would be good
to ensure good quality childcare a lot
of the childcare that exists now is not
good quality and so all the research is
done says that childcare is beneficial
to children but that research is done on
good quality childcare because poor
quality childcare doesn't let
researchers in oh we know that a lot of
the care is not good quality and we know
that this is not a good thing that our
children are being raised in in
situations that are not helping them to
grow and develop at a national level I
would like to see a childcare system we
don't have a childcare system we have
lots of people trying to get childcare
and one of the women who comes to talk
in my class is a GSB graduate she's
married to another GSB graduate their
issue is not financial they have enough
money but when she became pregnant she
put her child on a waiting list at a
childcare center the day she knew that
she was pregnant the child was born
approximately nine months later and she
wanted to go back to work three months
after that so it was almost a year that
the child had been on the waiting list
and they had no slot for the child it
didn't matter what she was willing to
pay there was no slot the other question
about childcare is affordability now
that was not her issue but many people
cannot afford the childcare that does
exist so we need a childcare system and
we needed to be subsidized for people
who who need the subsidy
[Music]
Fremont was proposing a ballot
initiative that would cost homeowners $1
a month $12 a year to provide
after-school childcare for Fremont
public school children and 86% of the
population voted this down and my
student was doing an exit poll because
we didn't know how the vote would come
but we were interested in why people
were voting however they were going to
vote had voted and what he found was
that most people said it's not my
problem if people don't have child care
they should figure it out I don't have
to pay $12 a year to help them figure
this out this is not this is not my
problem I think we need to look globally
we need to look beyond just our own
satisfaction or our country's
satisfaction because we are a global
economy we are a global entity and I'll
never forget when you know the
astronauts saw the Earth from the moon
and saw how we were a single entity and
pollution in one place affects pollution
and other and you know nuclear power
affects the whole world so I think all
of us need to be thinking more broadly
than ourselves or our families to our
country and then to the world as a whole
and I think that's the challenge of our
current moment is how to get us to think
more broadly
[Music]